on a tous entendu parler de la maladie
de lyme qui est transmise par les tiques
à pattes noires
c'est un set serait en progression dans
le sud du québec
à la faveur du réchauffement du climat
mais des hivers moins rigoureux
profiterait à une autre tic qui
s'attaque elle aux orignaux les
chasseurs québécois en signal de plus en
plus à un point tel qu'on s'inquiète
désormais pour les populations de ces
grands cervidés
c'est le plus grand et le plus puissant
de tous les cervidés
l'orignal est parfaitement adaptée aux
rigueurs de l'hiver
mais qu'arrive-t-il quand son
environnement se transforme
quand le climat change son habitat à
vitesse grand v
voici la tique divers
elle profiterait du réchauffement du
climat pour progresser vers le nord ce
minuscule parasites pourrait-il menacé
le plus grand cervidé de la planète
c'est
ce spécialiste du ministère de la faune
gère une espèce en excellente santé
jamais l'orignal n'a été aussi abondants
au québec
mais christian du sou et préoccupé
latics d'hiver a le potentiel d'avoir un
impact important sur nos populations de
réunion puis comme on souhaite faire une
gestion durable de cette espèce là c'est
important savoir quelle proportion
quel pourcentage de la population va
mourir par ce parasite l'eau c'est super
important
[Musique]
on va employer une méthode de capture
qui a été fait souvent la tique et
présentes à l'état naturel dans le sud
du québec
mais ces deux chercheurs croient qu'elle
fait plus de ravages qu autrefois la
barrière du climat ne protègerait plus
les orignaux du québec c'est au dessin
au seul dollar de répartition à nos
collègues des états unis ça fait ça fait
plusieurs années que la préoccupation
intériorité ils voient leur population
diminuer lyon des suivis d'engager avec
des jours si on voit ce qui se passe au
sud on se dit bon ça sent bien chez nous
ces images ont frappé les esprits dans
l'état du new hampshire aux états unis
la tique d'hiver a fait chuter de moitié
le cheptel de réunion
[Musique]
c'est dans la végétation qu'elle est
large des tic voit le jour en été
l'automne elle s'accroche un orignal et
passer l'hiver à se nourrir de son sang
l'augmentation de sa taille est alors
spectaculaire au printemps la tique se
détache de l'animal et retourne au sol
pour pondre ses oeufs à l'aéroport de
québec christian dussault a rassemblé
des spécialistes de la capture des
grands mammifères cette équipe d'élite
débute la plus importante recherche
jamais entreprise sur la tique divers
dans l'est du pays
l'objectif aujourd'hui on voit sur
l'état pour quatre niveaux aux réunions
pour les munir essentiellement d'un
collier télémétrie puis on l'est on va
faire un paquet de mesures aussi sur ces
animaux là pour évaluer leur état de
santé puis
les présences de tricks or c'est sur ces
animaux
les terres du séminaire joutes de
l'arrière pays de charlevoix
c'est un des lieux de capture les plus
au nord de cette vaste étude les
capturerons des zones les plus chaudes
au nouveau brunswick aux régions les
plus froides et enneigées comme celle de
charlevoix
cette diversité de climats et capitale
c'est ce qui permettra de déterminer les
influences du froid sur la montée des
tic vers le nord après une heure de vol
l'équipe repère enfin sa cible
il faut maintenant isolé le veau de sa
mère pour le capturer comme les veaux
sont plus vulnérables aux tic
c'est sur eux que les biologistes
mesureront le taux de mortalité
après quelques essais l'animal est enfin
à portée de tir
la bête est rapidement maîtrisé très
vite on lui donne un sédatif pour la
calmer
l'équipe commence par l'examen de santé
j'ai pensé pour chaque vos captures et
on prélève un échantillon de sang neuf
les veaux pour une charge de parasites
équivalente vont se faire siphonner se
fait plus de 100 par la sic en
proportion de volume total de cinq
saisons dans leur cas donc ils vont
souffrir davantage d'années me ils vont
être plus faible soit le sursaut ça
pourrait on évalue ensuite la présence
des tic
d'ailleurs ne peut ici une grosse cette
plaie témoignent de leur nombre
quand j'exprime c'est un vrai j'ai quand
même un festival d des bonnes claques le
où il ya pas de poils puis dans le
décompte qu'on a fait sur les tic le
stand by qui sent le cas mais on en voit
beaucoup le latic vos recrée des
démangeaisons c'est chez l'animal
n'entraîne mal pour se débarrasser de
leurs tickets pour ça et rating va va
s'arracher du poil va se frotter sur les
armes
donc ça va créer des plaques de peau
sont exposées à l'air libre
la tique ne tue pas directement l'animal
les pellets parfois nombreuses entraîne
des pertes importantes de chaleur tout
au long de l'hiver au dos après
l'énergie perdue pourrait
considérablement affaibli receveaux d'à
peine neuf mois en grèce et en envoyant
à 3,89 son émetteur exigera ou
biologiste c'est l'éthique lui seront
fatales
[Musique]
nous sommes à la fin de l'hiver
christian dussault surveillent avec
attention les déplacements de chacun de
ces aux réunions des tic ont pompé du
sang tout l'hiver certaines bêtes sont
maintenant au bout de leurs réserves
on est alerte on observe régulièrement
nos courriels pour connaître les statuts
de survie de nos animaux puis dès qu'une
mortalité survient on est prêt à sortir
sur le terrain aller investiguer
l'orignal capturé dans charlevoix a
finalement survécu
mais tous n'ont pas eu cette chance à
l'université laval
l'équipe de jean pierre tremblay prend
la relève
pour chaque carcasse récupérer on
détermine la cause de mortalité
à cette étape chacun des restes de
l'orignal est précieux
ce fragment de pau par exemple est un
élément clé il va révéler la gravité de
l'infestation au moment de la mort
on observe clairement sur certaines
carcasses des charges de type cloud et
des états du pelage de l'animal qui sont
un éducateur de la réponse à la tique
donc on observe qu'elle eut des effets
des faits importants de la tique sur sur
cet animal dont qui avait pu mener
jusqu'à sa mortalité
au total sur la centaine de bêtes
capturées le tiers des orignaux est mort
beaucoup avaient d'importantes quantités
de tic
pourtant certains se trouvaient dans des
régions qui étaient autrefois réputés
trop froide pour l'attique
[Musique]
jusqu'où ira la tic dans sa migration
vers le nord
pour répondre à cette question les
chercheurs doivent franchir un autre pas
en plus du climat
ils doivent aussi tenir compte de la
végétation
[Musique]
nous sommes en automne
là où un orignal muni d'un émetteur est
mort les tic ont trouvé refuge dans
cette végétation les chercheurs imite le
passage d'un orignal
il récolte les tic qui ont survécu
[Musique]
l'endroit vos tombes ils vont être
déterminants pour pour déterminer son
succès est ce qu'on va trouver à
l'automne ça va dépendre des tic qui
vont réussir survie déposer leurs oeufs
et avant les conditions qui fait que les
césures vont éclore en ou septembre
[Musique]
en couplant les données sur l'abondance
des tic et les types de végétation
les chercheurs seront en mesure
d'élaborer une carte des risques
d'infestation c'est un outil important
à terme on pourrait envisager des
travaux forestiers dans les habitats à
risque pour l'orignal la carte de
risques c'est celle qui nous permet de
comprendre les zones les plus les plus
chaudes dont il use c'est plus dangereux
pour un orient sont rudes de fréquenter
ces éditeurs à l'automne donc si on est
capable de 200 morceaux et que les
caractéristiques de la bête en question
sont aménageables alors on pourrait peut
être intervenir
[Musique]
le cheptel de réunion a doublé en 30 ans
au québec
la tique divers ralentir at elle cette
progression
à certains endroits les populations
montre déjà des signes de ralentissement
il faudra encore quatre années aux
chercheurs pour compléter cette
importante étude et tirer leurs
conclusions
pour jean pierre tremblay cet effort de
recherche est primordial il en va de la
santé d'une espèce qui est l'un des
symboles les plus importants de notre
fonds de 20 espèces qui vient nous
chercher dans nos racines puis qu'on
soit québécois ou qu'on soit une
personne des premières nations c'est ça
nous identifient c'est un oubli ou
territoires c'est une espèce clip pour
nos sociétés
[Musique]